I'm glad that our shows have brought you
that joy and that happiness because
that's what we get up to do every day is
to make someone else's life better it's
been a heavy burden to carry for for 10
years we're dealing with all of the
legal drama that we've had to deal with
since 2010 and we're dying on the inside
Todd Chrisley admits how his family
really feels about their reality show
Chrisley Knows Best I would love to say
it's all scripted but you can't script
the dysfunction that goes on
series premiered on the USA Network back
in 2014. in a year we probably spend 300
000 sometimes more just on clothing I
approve every piece of clothing that our
children wear her shorts are too big
they need to be smaller smaller or
larger they still look like is I think
that any family in this country has
gossip and chatter I think that ours is
just now going to be broadcast to a much
larger level people can't say anything
about us that we don't already know
and although things might seem fun and
lighthearted on Chrisley Knows Best Todd
and Julie reveal on their Chrisley
confessions podcast behind closed doors
it's a whole different story I don't
think that the fans truly know sometimes
that the happiness that we're bringing
you is that some of our saddest times
when our show started it was supposed to
be a doctor series full reality and the
world took our show and turned it into a
comedy and it's been a heavy burden to
carry for for 10 years we're dealing
with all of the legal drama that we've
had to deal with since 2010 and we're
dying on the inside but we still have to
put a smile on your face I think that
this show is going to go on for as long
as people tuning in and they want to
know what's going on in our lives and
while the Chrisleys say we only see
their happiest moments on TV they're not
holding anything back when it comes to
their podcasts Todd and Julie started
their Chrisley confessions podcast in
2018 and their daughter Savannah jumped
on the podcast train last month debuting
her show unlocked with Savannah Chrisley
you and Dad's podcast it's going great
per usual I'm still trying to beat you
but you know kind of hard with Chrisley
confessions
you'll get there and trust me I've
always wanted to do a podcast I just
never really made it a priority and then
I just got to a point where I was like
all right I need an outlet for myself
like my mental health is more important
than all these other projects that I
have going on and I need an outlet to
voice how I'm feeling meanwhile Todd's
other daughter from a previous marriage
Lindsay has two podcasts coffee convos
and the southern tea where I'm ready for
it to be a new year there's been so many
things that have gone on that I'm just
kind of over it and ready to start fresh
and to have a little bit of a break and
while the Chrisleys seem all in on their
podcasts they aren't abandoning TV
anytime soon Todd reveals they have a
new project in the works now we're at a
much better place with new show content
that's going to be coming out that's
going to be giving you a whole new
perspective of the Chrisley family and
you are gonna you are going to get to go
through the ups and the downs and and
everything that we're going through and
you are going to hear
the little bit that you may have heard
in the tabloids you'll get to hear the
whole story the documentary that's being
that we're working on right now is going
to be very telling and we hope that our
fans will Embrace that
[Music]